[Music]
howdy y'all my name is Brent wiggler I'm
the director of customer success at
spark cognition and this is Ben Wilson
my partner yeah I'm his partner glad
y'all are here you know when people see
people like us right they know we're
from Texas and usually what they're
thinking about in their head is usually
this they think this is what goes on in
Texas but I don't really think it does
and what's really interesting about this
is we were told by the Google press
people that might be offense of the
Cowboys but we didn't find it that
offensive but what really happens in
Texas what you actually think about
Texas maybe some Texas barbecue Willie
Nelson South by South use ik but South
by Southwest but what we really think of
Texas is big houses and no state income
tax so so what Ben and I are here to
talk to you guys today about we're going
to talk about GCP and spark cognition
I'm gonna do a little bit of an intro
into who we are in spark cognition and
then we're gonna walk through an oil and
gas customer use case again my name is
Brent I'm the director of customer
success at spark ignition you can think
of that as a quasi product manager slash
Engagement Manager role my background is
an oil and gas I spent a number of years
at Schlumberger both as a consultant and
an engineer so for those of you who
haven't heard about us spark ignition
we're an AI machine learning software
provider we have three main products in
this space the first one which I'll be
heavily focusing on today is a product
we call Darwin which is for automated
machine learning we have a second
product called spark predict which is a
software that allows users to interact
with the outputs of models so for an oil
and gas customer you can think of being
able to interpret the output of a model
and make decisions based on based on the
statistics of the data sets that are
coming in and the third product is a
natural language processing product that
we have to help users or help industrial
companies sort of make sense of
maintenance logs as well as as well as
the other like NLP applications that
they might have we've been working on
delivering solutions to markets in 2014
and we're based in Austin Texas as you
could probably tell
we raised fifty six million dollars in
our series be
that was earlier this year from the
likes of Boeing's horizon X investment
group inventor G's future fund inventor
G's a large wind wind provider as well
as Verizon ventures and we list the
number of companies not just oil and gas
focused where we're in the government we
have financial applications aviation
utilities and manufacturing and we've
been highly ranked on some disruption
disruptors lists so the idea of what
we're going through today is a product
that we have called Darwin and I'm gonna
go into a lot more details about what
Darwin actually is but it's a mushy
automated machine learning tool and it
differentiates itself in many different
ways but as of right now Darwin sits on
Google cloud and you can access Darwin
on Google cloud it's a user makes a call
to Darwin's API which they can upload
data to Google storage and it uses
Google compute to actually do a lot of
the machine learning work that's that's
happening behind the scenes and I'll go
into a lot more detail about how it
actually works and and the it'll get a
little bit of technical so look forward
to that awesome you didn't press the
button every okay so we're here to talk
about how machine learning works in the
oil and gas industry for me one of the
things I like to think about when I
think about machine learning is what
platform you're gonna build upon when I
think about a platform I think about it
in basically three main ways the first
because many people around the world
rely on Google Gmail maps and of course
the all-important cat videos Google has
created a rock-solid infrastructure that
you can rely on so if you are gonna go
build a petabyte size scale seismic data
Lake or are you gonna do seismic
interpretation this is a performant
environment that you can work upon the
second I'd like to talk about is our
service data platform here we've built a
unique platform that allows you to spend
more time analyzing your data and
understanding your data and less time
caring and feeding your production
applications or your seismic
applications so you're allowed to go
down deep into your data and be able to
really make decisions third because we
do we believe deeply in the power of
developers we have a developer centric
platform and what we like to do is we
like to let developers do what they love
most and that's code while we manage the
deploying the
a lien of that code so that they don't
have to oops I missed I forgot to press
that button there we go let developers
just code we this platform is actually
in five regions right are in 15 regions
right now expanding to fifteen are five
more these data centers are all over the
world and probably within reach and
these data centers do things that are
absolutely fantastic and they have
technology that just is unsurpassed to
give you a little taste of that when you
think about bandwidth when you think
about bandwidth and you think about by
sectional bandwidth the entire Internet
has a by sectional bandwidth of roughly
200 terabits a second now that sounds
like a lot but when you take a peek
inside a Google Data Center and we have
thirteen hundred terabytes a second four
by sectional bandwidth we feel pretty
confident that we can handle almost any
network intensive application that you
might have things like seismic
interpretation as just yet under yet an
example now I put this slide up and this
is always an interesting one especially
when I show it to an energy grip because
they look at it's like wow that's a lot
of dots that's a lot of lines like okay
you have nice network why is this
important well we have the we operate
the largest backbone network in the
world third parties estimate roughly 25%
of all Internet traffic travels across
Google's network on any given day we
have more than a hundred points of
presence across 33 locations at 33
countries and continue to be scaling
regions and zones every day to meet
customers preferences and preferences
and policy requirements now I said we
have a large network the question is
when you look at that how big is that
that's roughly a hundred thousand by up
miles of fiber-optic network that is
huge now we like we'd like to think we
have the largest but we can't actually
prove it because our competitors don't
actually publish that information but
one thing that we all do publish our
cash nodes and we have roughly 800 cash
nodes throughout the whole world and
those those little grey boxes there are
grey circles there we like to think that
Google's well provisioned highly
reliable global network matters to
customers who care about privacy and
security and that
almost every single customer one of the
reasons were able to go do this is
because we do something that's called
cold potato now you might ask what is
cold potato cold potato is this
basically it means that what what Google
does is we hold onto a data packet as
long as possible before it gets the
end-user and we do that because we want
to provide security and privacy but we
also want to make sure it's very
performant when you look at other cloud
providers generally what they do is they
play hot potato they get your packet and
they want to pass it off to an ISP as
soon as possible
and it might be on an ISP that might
have the reliability the privacy of
quality services quality of service that
you might get inside Google Cloud
I actually think highly performant
networks are really really important if
you go talk to Ninh antic as an example
that a makeup pokeyman go one of the
things that they did is they looked at
Google's Network and said hey that's a
great network for our application for
our game and turned out to be the
fastest growing game in the internet and
they had to have a network like ours to
make it work but the question you have
to ask yourself is if you're in the
energy business why does this really
matter right I'm not making games I'm
actually going and looking for oil and
gas where I'm producing electricity
since most oil and gas companies or
energy companies are all over the world
they need secure communications in
places like Africa Western Australia all
over Asia Alaska we have a network there
we have edge nodes and pops everywhere
so you can make sure that your data is
going to be your data is gonna get there
performing and also securely now when I
I talk about the platform I'm really
enamored with it because I'm a developer
and I'd like to do these things the
question is what are others thinking
right in this case this is Forrester and
this is their wave chart and they happen
to put us in the leader circle I like
that I think it's true but I like to
think it's more because you know we have
integrated thing new things together
like languages like go kubernetes
container clusters globally scalable
scalable databases like spanner and
we've also got that global network all
over the world with more regions coming
on that allows you to have the best
experience that's highly reliable and
secure now for me one of the reasons I
like spark-ignition is I like to think
that's one of the reason
why they decided to build on Google
cloud platform so with that let me hand
it over and you can go on Thanks sure
yes so as Ben mentioned you know a lot
of our why we chose GCP was because it
was driven by our engineers so in that
case we we decided to put Darwin which
is our automated machine learning
product onto Google cloud so what is
Darwin and what is it in the context of
the industrial space and especially in
oil and gas so I'm gonna go through a
little bit about how it works and what's
happening behind the scenes and then
we'll get into an oil and gas use case
so for those of you who aren't aware of
the issues with industrial datasets
we're essentially working on sensor
information coming off of big machines
and sensors are really inconsistent and
untrustworthy
there's sparse labels so people are not
sitting there you know labeling all of
the information that comes off of it
which is mostly required for adequate
machine learning and it's not prepped
for adequate data science right so if we
look at two separate wind turbines I go
through the wind turbine example because
it's a lot easier for people to
understand relative to oil and gas
examples but essentially if you have
wind turbines in two separate locations
those are gonna require two separate
machine learning models a wind turbine
in location a might have a different
failure profile or predictive profile
than one in failure in in location B an
operator that runs a wind farm might
operate their farm differently in then
another one the sensor packages that are
on a wind turbine will be different and
the actual turbine that's actually
running on the on the in the wind farm
those will be different between two
separate locations so what does that
mean that actually means that you cannot
build one model that will run on both of
these there needs to be a scalable
solution an automated solution that can
build specific models for each
individual asset so when we looked at
this problem when we started out and we
started receiving a lot of information
from industrial companies looking for
data science work we ended up having too
many customers too many customer
requests for the existing data that we
had so these were some of the internal
factors that we need that we were
looking at to need to build an automated
solution in addition to actually build a
model for each individual turbine that's
a that's a time intensive process the
current solution
that we're offering were not scalable
and there was clearly a lack of an
automated solution on the market that
actually could Purdue predictions for
each individual asset some of the
external factors that point us to
automation and I went through a lot of
these but there's a lot of variation
from different assets depending on
location what's on the assets and all
that kind of stuff in addition you
needed something to solve problems with
sparse data and noisy data as well so
when we saw all of these problems we
were we went through and we said okay
let's look at the workflow of a data
scientist and figure out what we can
automate around so for a data scientist
the first thing that you do is you go
through a data cleaning step right you
you take your data you do any sort of
imputation or any sort of methods to
sort of make it into a into a functional
data set then you go through your
feature engineering practice and you try
to figure out what features you need to
engineer what you can drop and all of
those sorts of little nuances that you
can that's sort of the magic of one
specific data scientist and then you
need to build a model and if that model
doesn't work depending on what tools you
use you go back and you revisit your
cleaning methods you go back and you
revisit your feature engineering methods
and you go back and you revisit your
model and it's inherently just an
iterative process that can take a very
long time now on two separate wind
turbines maybe you can expedite this by
just having a background knowledge of
what usually works but in essence it's
not going to be you don't need a person
or a data science team to actually build
a model for each individual asset so all
of this requires a high amount of
technical expertise a lot of time and
there's there was a lack of product
ization tools out there that that that
could solve all these problems so we
went out and we tried to build something
that could automate the data cleaning
process automate the feature engineering
process and especially automate the
model building process so I'm going to
take a quick technical segue to talk
about how we went through this and and I
hope that everyone can stick with me on
this so when we talk about automating
the the feature engineering process and
cleaning step I'll get to that in a
second but our approach towards model
building this is an image of a neural
network there are three layers inside of
this neural network and each circle is
essentially math happening at each
circle and each line you can think about
that is like a coefficient that happens
at each line now what a data scientist
did is they designed what this looks
like so we're all those circles are and
we're all those lines are a data
scientist said this is the structure of
the network that I want and when machine
learning does is it goes and just tries
to figure out what waits or what
coefficients happen at each one of those
lines now if this is not the optimal
network structure there's no way to
determine what actually might be it just
that you're you're leveraged to whatever
data scientists is inherent knowledge or
whatever is in a library that already
exists so what we did was we how can we
automate the search for the right
network topology or what structure
actually works best for a specific data
set so we went through and we built a
product that leverages neural evolution
so it uses evolutionary algorithms to
actually search for the network
architecture that solves this problem
and it not only searches for the network
architecture it chooses different
imputation methods for cleaning it
chooses different features after
features are generated automatically and
it searches for the network optimization
architecture that is perfect for or
optimized for the actual data set that
it's being trained on so how does it do
this so you upload your data set and in
the first generation you build 70
different neural networks and we also
combined it with some tree based
algorithms and in that generation we
look at what are the genomes of those
specific models that worked the best to
make those models accurate those genomes
then get mutated into the next
generation and spawned 70 new neural
networks off of those in itself of that
initial population and we go through
that process again we take the genomes
from the best-performing models we
mutate and breed them into the next
generation and we spawn off 70 new
models again and that happens for n
number of generations so in this case
now you can upload your data set and it
will do all of the feature engineering
the data cleaning process and the
network search the network architecture
search specific to the data set that you
uploaded to and this is really important
when we talk about things like wind
turbine a versus wind turbine
you're actually doing a lot of the steps
specific to this to the asset that it's
being trained upon so what do these
networks end up looking like so here's
three separate use cases it's
essentially used case agnostic the one
on the Left predicts bearing failure
that's the architecture that was trained
off of 400 generations the one in the
middle
we trained to essentially mimic one of
our in-house pilots using a using a
flight simulator to try and determine
exactly how his his flight path works
and the one on the right that I've kind
of blacked out here trades down futures
so when you talk about deep learning you
can see how how big a model can actually
bet get by just doing this generative
process and running it for however many
generations you see fit so again it's
use case agnostic it's not necessarily
specific to industrial applications
although that that's where our DNA is
we've kind of grown up in the industrial
space working on wind turbines and oil
and gas assets but with that I'm going
to kind of go through what the oil and
gas application is that we've used this
for so for those of you who are not
familiar with the oil industry there's a
there's a concept called artificial lift
so when you first produce from an oil
well the natural pressures of the well
will lift fluids to the surface so and
if you've ever seen those images of oil
spewing out from the top of a derrick
that's because the natural pressure of
the earth is pushing that oil up now
after a certain amount of time the
pressure starts to subside you produced
a lot from a reservoir you need a way to
be able to lift that oil out of the
ground so the sucker rod pump on the
left there's about a million of these in
operation around the world what this is
essentially doing is if you've ever had
a cup of water with a straw in it you
put your thumb over the straw and lift
up and you see the column of fluid come
up with it it's essentially just doing
that on repeat so it's just kind of
sucking all of the oil out of the ground
an electric submersible pump is
essentially a pump that you've lowered
into the ground and it can it turns and
pumps oil to surface so after at a
certain point in the in the production
of a reservoir after the pressure is
subside you can no longer produce to the
to the surface you start implementing
all of these artificial lift systems and
with these there are many different
manufacturers they
been in place since the early 1940s
there's a variety in every field the
same aspects of what I went through with
the wind turbines different fields have
different profiles different sensors are
put on each piece of machine and
different operators have different
tactics in order to make sure that
they're optimizing these specific assets
so with this we were we worked with a
company that we one of our partners a /
G a / G is one of the biggest
software providers that actually
monitors a lot of these assets so you
can think about a monitoring software
that's streaming information directly
from these artificial lift systems into
into their platform and there's all of
their data kind of sits inside of their
monitoring software and production
analysts and specialists look through
this information and try and make
determinations on what's going to fail
what's going to optimize those sorts of
things a purge he also sits across
wide-ranging applications both in
drilling for oil as well as producing it
so even though we're talking
specifically about these artificial lift
systems here we're eventually going to
start moving into more and more of these
like really complex applications you can
go all the way up to drilling
applications as well but for this as you
see circled on the left we're focusing
on the artificial lift systems so the
way that this works in practice
is that an ESP in the field will stream
data directly into an Apogee Apogee
software where someone can make
interpretations off of what's actually
happening inside of the well and make
decisions and then we'll take that data
either through an API or through just
like a downloaded CSV from their
software and put it into Darwin where
that will build a predictive model and
Darwin sits in Google Cloud that model
can then be put back into a / G software
and any user any producer can actually
just make determinations off of the
prediction model now for us
Darwin sits you can either we have it as
a standalone software and I'm going to
go through that demo you can upload CSV
is just the software that sits on the
cloud or you can you can leverage it in
sort of an API call connection to
to any sort of monitoring software there
now here I talk about this specific of
this specific monitoring software but
you can imagine it being any sort of any
sort of monitoring software or business
intelligence tool that you want to put
it into I had an executive come to me
and say well when in the context here
what do you guys mean about bi tool and
I said yeah you don't even know we're
thinking so far past a I know that
didn't hit that well that's a bad joke
now that hit a lot harder that's already
thinking past AI so I'll go through the
demonstration of how this actually works
so I'm gonna upload this data set what
this data set is is all of the
information that's coming off of this
electric submersible pump this is an
electric submersible pump so it's the
one that you lower into the ground and
it pumps oil to surface what we're
trying to do is do a prediction on how
much oil it will produce within the next
seven days so off of the sensor we're
getting some metadata on where this will
is actually located production figures
so oil water gas oil well doesn't just
produce oil it produces a mixture of oil
water gas and other sorts of dead
dinosaur stuff and then you also have
the tubing pressure casing pressure and
all of the sensors coming off of the
pump and well again what we're trying to
get to is just a very simple prediction
of what the next seven day forecast will
be
so within our software and this is the
software version you can also set it up
where it's just builds models
automatically through a connection but
what we're going to go through is here
I've already built all of these models
they're basically cards that sit on side
the software and when I want to create
it but see if it starts playing I go
create new model and I can upload or
name the model that I want to create in
this case it's seven-day production
forecast I can give it a description and
then I have I'm given all of these
workflows so infer values forecast
values in four categories find patterns
or predict events so in this case we're
trying to build a library of these sorts
of cards that depending on the workflow
people want this can sort of organize
the data set in that fashion infer
values is a simple regression forecast
values is just shifting that sort of
target column to be able to forecast
predict something in the future in four
categories this is a this is a
classification find patterns is our
clustering approach and predicting
normal predict events as our our
strategy towards predicting a point in
time in this case we're going to go
ahead and we're going to infer values so
I go to this card and click and four
values you can kind of go through and
see all of the if you have any questions
on the software you can go through and
here I'm pointed to I want to upload a
drag and drop my data set give a little
description of what the data set should
look like so we try and formulate
everything in these rectangular formats
where if you think about this as an
excel file or CSV all of your all of
your inputs are in rows or in columns
and every time stamp is in rows and one
of your predicted outputs is in this in
one of the in the target column
so you go find your data set
you can visualize your data set here and
then you can go ahead and select the
targeted column so in this case you're
going to go ahead and select the column
that is oil production prediction click
Next and then you're driven to a point
where you can choose how much how long
you want to train your model for or how
long you want to go through how many
generations you actually want to go
through and actually build this build
this network architecture obviously the
longer you train for the more it should
converge we're giving out metrics as
well to make sure that you can see how
well it's converging over time but this
as of right now is is sort of a you can
just determine the amount of time that
you want to wait for this to train for
there's also advanced features you can
change the accuracy targets for this we
use normalized root mean squared error
but now we're building our model behind
the scenes is going through this process
of building models turn determining the
right genomes mutating those into the
next generation and continually going
through that process until we derived
the network architecture specific to
this data set we give out the statistics
on this specific model so you can see
how accurate the models got over
generation or over time you can look at
all of the statistics around the data
set that you've uploaded in addition you
can eventually get to the point where
you're looking at feature importances
here's the graph of the actual output so
you can see your predicted versus actual
and see how that trends over time and
then you can look at your feature
importances or here you can see the in
an excel format or CSV format the
predicted versus actual in this case now
you get to the point where you can look
at what features are actually driving
these predictions so this is the
model-based
prediction feature importances for this
specific ESP for the model for this
specific ESP and once you have your
model built you have a number of options
either you can run meaning test your
model on unseen data you can publish it
or improve meaning upload your data in
upload new data to train the model
further you can publish it that means
making an API call to the model that you
have or you can download it in the
pickle file format that we have so you
can put into a runtime engine and now
we're going to we're going to upload a
test set
so uploading the test set you can upload
your code in the same format as drag and
drop
and you have your predictions so here is
now the predictions on the next test set
we're doing seven days production
forecasting and now you have your model
built you can see the testing accuracy
and in addition we actually give out
another feature we that gives you a per
prediction feature importance so when I
click on a value I can see I can see
what's driving this prediction down and
or more less accurate and what's driving
this prediction to become more accurate
so on a per prediction basis now you can
see what's actually driving your
predictions so here through this entire
tool we went through the process of
uploading a data set from an ESP
building a model to predict the next the
forecasted values of the next seven days
production and then being able to look
at the model output and test it on new
data sets and see each individual
prediction and what drives that up or
down so even more than that the way that
I like to think about this from the oil
and gas perspective is what decisions
can I actually make off of this model
that I've now built so in this case what
I've gone and done is I've uploaded the
date I have the test setup there and I
changed some of the control parameters
that I have as an operator so in this
case I can make the pump pump faster or
I can make the pump pump slower and I
can see how that impacts my production
outcome so the gray line here is the
actual changed production where the
orange line is what was originally
predicted so when I make control
parameter changes to my pumps I can see
how this impacts my production figures
and now prediction becomes part of my
optimization plan so in this case the
average production increased by changing
the pump parameters increased by seven
hundred barrels per week and now you can
go ahead and just make changes and see
how that might impact the optimization
of your ESP now for those of you who are
oil and gas people you might look at
this and say well it's really actually
kind of rare to have a production figure
per per per well so in in actuality what
happens is you have upwards of sixty
wells producing into one massive tank
and inside of that one tank is where you
get your production figures so in this
case you actually have all of these
wells that are used
different types of artificial lift
systems different types of operated
possibly by different people in
different fields and they're all going
into one battery that actually is
producing that's that's the only
targeted outcome so for the first one I
went through I had this seven-day
production forecast that seven-day
production forecast is specific to that
well in actuality you'll have 60 wells
that are producing it to that one
forecast so now your optimization is how
do I change all of these pump parameters
in order to make sure that I'm driving
the most production yeah I mean for me
I'm for those of you who've actually
operated batteries and operated pumps
this is like the realistic situation
I've done a whole bunch of like AI
trying to do prediction and also try to
do preventative maintenance to try to be
able to predict failures and the biggest
challenge is is being able to go out
there and say okay I have a battery has
got 60 wells odds are all 60 wells we're
not drilled by me they were drilled by
probably three or four other parties
they have three or four different sites
of equipment they have different types
of sensors so being able to be have this
iterative approach to go in and looking
at the data that's coming off and being
able to do predictions by well makes a
huge difference you can think about it
from an operational perspective and how
full is that tank gonna be you can also
look at it just from a maintenance
perspective too so when I look at this
as an operator I look at it and say this
is really really important one other
thing I'd say too is in case you don't
recognize the name Apogee that used to
be Dover yes and most people recognize
Dover as one of the largest artificial
lift manufacturers in the world and when
you think about artificial lift you know
you think about those pushing them down
into the into the well and usually put
three or four or five of these things
together and be able to get these things
to operate correctly across a set of
batteries like this really complex so
this really does simplify that process I
will also mention is if you didn't see
the dev key notes today they actually
did all of theirs live they didn't use
video like you did yeah next time we
need to do it live yeah I appreciate
that thanks Ben yeah I'm here to help
yeah I mean the big thing here is what
we're going after is the scale of the
problem that's actually at hand here
where there's you know upwards of a
million of these wells and operation
around the world so being able to build
these models automatically
and through the tool that we built is is
a huge benefit to to a lot of oil and
gas operators and being able to make
these changes and optimization plans you
know in real time and see how that
impacts the predictive - prediction
production is gonna be pretty huge the
kind of back to Darwin for a second I
know that I kind of pit you know I
pitched it originally as this sort of
use case agnostic position and in
reality we've tested it on a number of
data sets we've done a number of capital
competitions as well where we've seen
that it's it's it's actually a pretty
useful tool depending on the the how
long you train it for or how long you
want to go through the process it's it's
it really does well for time series
especially when we add sort of
recurrency aspects or looking back into
the past components the model building
tilt in case you don't recognize oh can
you got to go back when I would get a
say something yeah Cagle credit card
fraud we Google owns kaggle and nice to
see that we can actually do something
right there huh some of the new things
that we're adding in here unsupervised
learning we've had some success with
with different approaches and
unsupervised learning before now we're
sort to automate and do a very similar
process for a Gaussian mixture model
variational auto encoder that's a fancy
speak for saying we're doing clustering
and dimensionality reduction in one step
in addition what we do what we call
normal behavior modeling where it's
trying to just predict normal or not
normal and what that actually looks like
we also use a very similar approach
towards leveraging the evolutionary
approach for building auto-encoders in
addition we're still working on our user
experience so any sort of feedback that
you have on and on what you'd like to
see or what those cards might look like
or workflows that we can sort of
automate to make sure that the that the
tool works for the design process we're
working on that as well and then we're
always working on speed and accuracy so
speed and the model development process
composes of both leveraging Google and
their expertise as well as our approach
towards making the evolutionary
algorithm smarter with that I mean it's
been awesome working with Google
it's been fun even though he kind of
makes fun of me a lot my job yeah I
thank you I'm Ben Wilson I'm the smarter
better-looking cowboy yeah
you're the better man cowboy hey we
appreciate you all being here yeah thank
you very much
[Music]